of buildings four  my partner saw wma on the balcony he  went back inside  the people we have in custody who had a  413 handgun on them are saying that he  was shot  firing a shotgun at them break  right there where right here coming up  you see your head where right there  standing up  with no shirt you're back they didn't  take shot fire you just fired shots at  us hey stay down  get back  we're code four officers are not headed  one shot  we're gonna need a rifle deployed over  there hey careful  you guys just stay down  okay so that's the second video so at  that point we're attempting to contain  the individual  our officers are behind cover he then  comes out again as you see on the video  and just indiscriminately fires in the  direction  of the citizens and our officers who are  behind cover